what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of Thrones update
video today I want to talk about the
spin-off shows that I know I am
personally dying to see once Game of
Thrones ends it sucks knowing that Game
of Thrones will one day end but there is
some light at the end of the tunnel
knowing that they have been working on
five different shows based within the
world of A Song of Ice and Fire
at first I wasn't gonna make a video
about this just yet but since I saw
george RR martin comment on this news
himself i figured I better put it out
there so I have some good news for you
today and as most of you know I have
been reporting on all of the news
revolving around the spin-off show so I
want to make sure you stay up-to-date
with what's going on during its early
production stages today's update is
compliments of Watchers on the wall who
I saw post this news first
but Entertainment Weekly revealed some
great news today about one of the
writers who is helping create one of the
pilots for the new series but george RR
martin himself also commented on this
news and what he said made me feel even
more confident that not only will we see
one of these shows sooner than later but
the new series could potentially be in
the hands of someone who truly knows the
story as good as anyone else out there
if you stayed up to date with my videos
then you should know that HBO announced
they hired four different writers to
work on four different spin-offs in
hopes of one of their pilots getting
picked up and turned into a successful
series but george RR martin wrote on has
not a blog that they actually had five
writers working on five different shows
but at the time george did not want to
reveal who this fifth writer was all he
could say was that the fifth writer knew
the story better than anyone else not
including himself a nilly oh and Linda
of course who all worked on the world of
Ice and Fire novel but today
Entertainment Weekly announced that
Bryan cogman is the fifth writer who is
actually working on the fifth potential
spin-off show some of you may or may not
know this but Bryan cogman is a game of
Thrones veteran he has worked on the
show since before it ever aired on HBO
many years ago and this news makes me
very happy because now we know that they
have a legitimate writer working on one
of the pilots someone who has a firm
grasp on the story and knows what the
hell is going on but there is something
you always have to keep in mind just
because they're working on five
different spin-offs does
mean all five of these will be turned in
his shows pilots are made all the time
and they never see the light of day but
HBO hopes that with them focusing on
making five different stories to
translate on the screen maybe one of
them will be good enough to get turned
into a successful series but now that I
know Bryan cogman is one of those
writers I am confident that not only
will one of them get picked up but I
think it might be his whose gets picked
let me read to you exactly what george
RR martin said today on his not a blog
website George said truth be told
we've had five scripts in various stages
of development for months which I
believed I mentioned before Bryan cogman
should need no introduction for any Game
of Thrones fan he's been part of the
show since the beginning since before
the beginning actually since he was
first hired as assistant to David
Benioff and DB Weiss way before the
series got on the air before even the
pilot had been filmed from those humble
beginnings he advanced a staff writer to
story editor to co-producer and producer
and supervising producer less formally
he has also been game of thrones' keeper
of the lore the guy who knew that canon
better than anyone except me though
sometimes I'm not even sure of that he's
written more episodes of Game of Thrones
than anyone by Dan and David including
some of our very best ones
if D&D have been the kings of Westeros
for these past seven seasons Bryan
cogman has surely been the Prince of
Dragonstone you should not expect to see
all five shows though at least not
immediately much as I might love the
idea HBO is not about to become the Game
of Thrones Network but we could possibly
see two or even three make it to the
pilot stage with one series emerging on
air in 2019 or 2020 and the others maybe
later if they come out as well as we all
hope then again maybe but I should not
speculate you folks get way too excited
truth is no one knows least of all me
for now suffice it to say that Bryan
cogman has signed on in warth world
personally I think this is amazing news
based on a few different things that
George said first as George said himself
that Bryan knows the history and lore
better than anyone except for himself of
course but this means Bryan
more about the story than even Dan and
Dave who are the men were responsible
for Game of Thrones but I think it's
safe to say that a lot of people know
the story better than Dan and Dave but
to hear George have confidence and
Brian's knowledge is extremely hopeful
that we could get a legitimate show that
can stay more faithful to the source
material considering he knows this world
really well but George also said Brian
series will be an adaption and one that
will throw most fans of the books I
think set during a very exciting period
of Westerosi history and I'll be working
with him every step of the way we're
gonna be co-creating this show that also
sounds we're leavin that George said he
would work with him every step of the
way and they're gonna be co-creating
this show now obviously George is a very
busy man but I want to believe that
George will be there with him as much as
possible and help guide him to making
another beloved show an authentic story
I don't know about all of you but this
has me very excited plus George said we
can see the show air between 2019 and
2020 and I have a feeling we will get a
spin-off show
shortly after Game of Thrones ends I
would say within a year of season 8
ending we're gonna get a new show and I
hope it's written by brian and george RR
martin that way we get the best show
possible
I think HBO is gonna want to keep the
momentum going by releasing the first
spin-off show soon after Game of Thrones
ends that way they don't lose too much
of the fan base but this is just my
opinion so what do you all think about
this news comment down below and let me
know if this makes you as excited as I
am to hear this also let me know what
spin-off show you would like to see the
most
George already said they're not gonna be
making Robert's rebellion or Dunkin eggs
so those are already off the table so it
has to be something else personally I
would love to see something about the
long night or maybe even something about
Valerio I think that would be very
interesting but even something like
Aegon's conquest would be phenomenal as
well I really don't know there are so
many options and I would actually watch
anything they release I don't care who
it's about or what time period if Bryan
and George are creating it together I'm
sure we're gonna love it but anyways
just let me know what you think thanks
for stopping by and watching a quick
video I do appreciate that as always and
I also want to thank my supporters on
patreon I really appreciate your general
ah city to this channel have a great
night everyone I will see you in the
comment section
bye
[Music]
you